like an arts like movies or books or
cheese when you make a video game you're
making a story with characters it's
awesome but you're also creating a whole
world for that story with its
programming but kind of like art - we
used to think video games are really
hard to make but then our teacher is
coding instead of playing games we're
making our own games we make up a story
and work together to create a whole
world around that story
it's really simple to get started our
teacher brothers going in about five
minutes
I thought of our meetings all lines of
text and stuff I didn't know it could be
like a visual thing doctor
you